بالنسبة لهؤلاء الأشخاص من الأصدقاء ، أصبحت الحياة الآن
تحت الأرض هذا الكهف موطنًا لـ 12
شخصًا بطانية على الأرض هي الراحة الوحيدة
في ظلام الشتاء القرفصاء أثناء
انتظارهم لخطر المرور.
دفعت الغارات الجوية التركية العائلات
من جميع أنحاء الجيب الكردي إلى
الكهوف والطوابق السفلية ، ويقول الكثيرون
هنا إنهم فقدوا أفرادًا من عائلاتهم في
الأسبوعين الماضيين منذ أن شنت تركيا
هجومها ، ويخيم حزن
تحت الأرض في الهواء الجوفي الذي لا معنى له ، فنحن
فقراء زوجي.  قُتل
ليس لدينا مكان نذهب إليه ما الذي
سنفعله في الحادية عشرة من العمر ، نعم يعني تقول إنها فقدت
والدها الأسبوع الماضي ، وهو مقاتل يدافع
عن قريتهم ، قُتل والدي وأنا
وأمي وإخوتي جميعًا هنا
في الكهف  مظلمة حقًا هنا ، لذا فنحن
خائفون لأن
الغارات
الجوية صاخبة حقًا.  يوضح ديو كيف حطمت الضربات الجوية
والمدفعية الشوارع ،
وترى تركيا أن الأكراد يمثلون تهديدًا لأن
القادة الأكراد سعوا منذ فترة طويلة لإقامة
دولة كردية مستقلة في المنطقة
، ودمرت بيوتنا بيوتنا ،
وهذا ما ألقى بالقنابل ، فقد فقدنا
منازلنا أطفالنا ، لا شيء هو  يسار
لماذا يحدث هذا لنا يقول
المدير العام لهذا المستشفى في مدينة أجنبية
إنهم غارقون في
عدد الجرحى في حرب واحدة. أم
[موسيقى]
حقًا كيف سأعيش بدونك
يقول الأطباء إنه أصيب بجروح قاتلة بسبب
القصف التركي على مدينة الاستبداد
يقول المسؤولون الأكراد إن عشرات
المدنيين قتلوا وأصيب المئات على
يد الجيش التركي حتى الآن على
الرغم من أن شبكة CNN لا تستطيع بشكل مستقل
تأكيد عدد القتلى بالضبط في بيان
لشبكة CNN قالت الحكومة التركية إنها
تستهدف فقط.  الإرهابيين وأن
الحساسية تظهر لتجنب إلحاق الضرر
بالمدنيين والأبرياء في
البيئة ، وتقدر الأمم المتحدة أن هناك 16000
شخص مختلفين.  مبعثرة لعبور
الإطار وتقول إن
السلطات المحلية تمنع بعض المدنيين من المغادرة
دون أن يفروا من
الناس ليجدوا الدفء والمأوى في أي مكان
يمكنهم فيه باولا جوراني
CNN